nick gillespie of Reason TV and I've got  a story spookier that harry reid guest  starring in The Vagina Monologues look  upon this balance sheet from Hell in  2009 the federal deficit was a  record-setting 1.4 trillion dollars for  over twelve percent of GDP the highest  level since World War 2 2010 and 2011  will match or beat that meaning that in  just three short years the federal  government will have bled more red ink  than Tiger Woods during his divorce  settlement the federal debt which is  made up of all annual deficits plus  interest on borrowed money is around  forty-five percent of GDP and is  projected to be ninety percent by 2020  which means that the government will be  sucking up more and more of your money  tomorrow just to pay for bailing out  citigroup and GM today  it's just like a chevy cobalt a living  death on the installment plan